exactly a hundred years ago the map of
the world was redrawn the biggest
conflict so far known to mankind the
first world war finally came to an end
in November 1918 the changes that
followed were perhaps more strongly felt
in the Middle East than in any other
region of the world especially due to
the collapse of the Ottoman Empire this
is the story of the First World War and
the impact that it is still having today
told from the perspective of Turkey and
the Arab world the first world war saw
the collapse of four great powers the
German and Russian empires and
austro-hungary the ultimate Empire was
also on the losing side its territories
were divided up by the victors they
promised the Turkish nationalists their
own state but Greece and France claimed
parts of the country with the biggest
city Istanbul controlled by the US and
the British the Turks were enraged a
young officer named Mustafa Kemal fought
successfully with the remnants of the
Ottoman army against Greek and Italian
forces the war hero later began calling
himself Ataturk the father of the Turks
he founded a modern nation-state
imposing disciplined authoritarian rule
Ataturk maintained a strict division
between the secular state and Islam the
country's dominant religion Turkey
remains to this day an independent
nation the bridge between east and west
the Arab people's in contrast were
unable to secure their independence
freed from the subjugation of the
Ottomans they found themselves instead
under British and French rule once it
became apparent that the Ottoman Empire
could not survive the war the British
and French organised clandestine talks
under a cloak of secrecy they decided
how to divide up the Middle East the
British claimed the city of Mosul and
its oil they also wanted Jerusalem as a
base to control the new state of
Palestine France meanwhile allowed
Britain a free hand in taking over
territory in return for demanding huge
war
operations from Germany both the French
and British initially pledged to
transform their Arab territories into
independent democracies which never came
about
instead resources and goodwill were
exploited
the legacy of the First World War still
weighs heavily on the Middle East
arbitrary borders and lack of democratic
structures profound mistrust of the West
or as one American historian put it the
end of the first world war in Middle
East was a peace to end all peace